[Musique]
elle l'invité politique pour clôturer ce
journal c'est ma belle à des qte bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez 49 ans habitant de lui
en cours depuis 15 ans vous allez
conduire aux élections municipales dans
la ville la liste de l'ue dmf vous êtes
le premier candidat connu dans les
yvelines de l'union des démocrates
musulmans français qui prévoit aussi
d'investir des candidats manquent la
ville mantes-la-jolie et les mureaux lui
dmf déjà c'est un mouvement qui est né
en 2012 quelles sont les valeurs que
défend le parti
les valeurs de vivre ensemble de partage
de des valeurs sociales économiques
également on essaie de comment dire de
rassembler les français autour de notre
projet et est de faire en sorte que
justement tous tous puissent être sous
la même enseigne avec une volonté de
défendre les minorités ça c'est un axe
fort c'est les français dans leur
majorité bien sûr mais les minorités en
particulier également qui souvent se
sentent rejetés par par nos politiques
on va dire après après chaque élection
l'udf c'est un parti qui est qui a été
accusé d'être un parti communautaire
notamment en raison de la présence du
mot musulman dans dans le non du
mouvement
que répondez-vous à cela à ces
accusations de communautarisme n'est
donc pas du tout à un parti
communautariste loin de là le terme
musulman peut renvoyer vers plusieurs
terminologie plusieurs définitions
la première la plus connue forcément
c'est la dimension religieuse pour
laquelle nous sommes ni compétents ni
référent nous laissons cela aux
commandes heroes aux organismes
compétents mais je dirais qu'il ya pas
de dimension religieuse pas besoin d'eux
c'est pour ça que il ya plusieurs comme
je l'expliqué il ya plusieurs dimensions
là vous avez une dimension culturelle
nous ne sommes pas non plus dans cette
catégorie là et vous avez aussi une
dimension je dirais qu'il est plus
démographique et donc c'est cette
population qui se sent stigmatisé
aujourd'hui comme beaucoup d'autres
minorités en france et c c'est
symbolique d'un échec social en fait 1 h
et d'intégration sociale de notre
gouvernement
tout simplement ou des politiques en
général au niveau de l'échiquier
politique c'est un parti qui situe
plutôt à gauche plutôt à droite rouge qu
elle vaut surtout à gauche surtout à
gauche
vous êtes d'ailleurs vous un homme de
gauche père d'une famille recomposée
vous êtes ingénieur en
télécommunications et informations et on
précise que c'est votre première
participation à un scrutin en tant que
quand tant que candidat pourquoi vous
avez décidé de vous lancer justement
dans cette démarche politique c'est
suite à on va dire un cheminement g je
suis également président d'une
association humanitaire sur lui en cours
depuis bientôt six ans et aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya une réelle
déconnexion on va dire entre entre la
mairie et les autres courtoisie
guyancourt toi bien sûr et mais aussi le
tissu social de notre ville tout
simplement
et j'ai voulu justement m'engager parce
que j'estimais qu'il y avait encore
beaucoup de choses à faire
propos ses habitants mais pourquoi avec
lulu dmf justement aujourd'hui l'udf
pour moi incarne réellement ce ce besoin
de réconciliation des français si besoin
d'une justice sociale équitable
tout simplement alors qu'ils ont course
est une ville de gauche depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale qui était
d'abord avec des maires communistes puis
socialiste vous pensez qu'une alternance
est possible alors toujours à gauche
puisque vous définissez un homme de
gauche mais une alternance est possible
avec lui encore je pense que oui je
pense que oui si on rappelle le contexte
est une ville qui a connu trois maires
en six ans françois de ligne et qui
était maire depuis 2002 et qui a rendu
son écharpe en 2016
marie-christine ne tenait qu'à lui a
succédé en 2019 avant de lui a succédé
en 2016 pardon avant de démissionner en
2019 pour raisons de santé françois
morteau et le nouveau maire est de guye
entrons depuis mai 2010 9 quel regard
vous portez sur le travail qui a été
mené par la mandature actuelle pendant
ces six ans pendant six saisons on va
dire que dans l'ensemble c'était assez
satisfaisant bien qu'aujourd'hui comme
je l'expliqué il ya une certaine
déconnexion qui s'est opéré au niveau de
la municipalité avec le reste de la
population
justement le fait qu' aujourd'hui vous
se trouvaient cinq listes c'est une
première à guyancourt
on a eu comme vous l'avez ceux
mentionnés il ya quelques instants trois
maires successifs pour un seul mandat
vraiment il ya un certain malaise qui
s'est instaurée à guyancourt do do ce
doux cette diversité on va dire deux
parties qui qui émerge aujourd'hui
pendant de votre programme quelques axes
forts une priorité déjà à l'éducation
avec une volonté affichée de lutter
contre le décrochage scolaire tout à
fait le décrochage scolaire est une est
un fléau qui comment dire qui gangrènent
un peu dans toutes les villes je dirais
est malheureusement à l'état actuel dans
l'état actuel des choses il ya très peu
de débouchés ou très peu d'alternatives
pour ces procès élèves pour ces enfants
qui ne se retrouvent plus en fait dans
le l'éducation en classique et donc nous
avons un projet justement pour la ville
concernant ce type de préoccupations
c'est notamment d'aider aussi à
l'orientation favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes est ce que
sur cet aspect il n'y a pas une carte à
jouer avec lui vs cul qui est présente
aussi sur le territoire l'université
versailles saint quentin et affective à
intégrer progressivement la grande
université paris saclay tout à fait ça
serait ça serait l'idéal de de tisser
des partenariats comme ça aussi bien
avec les universités qu'avec les
entreprises locales étant donné que
guyancourt et quand même une ville assez
riche de par cette cette diversité de
travail autres axes de votre programme
c'est lutter contre la congestion
routière est ce que c'est une nécessité
quand on sait que à guyancourt va
arriver cette grande ligne cette grande
ligne de métro la ligne 18 qui est
prévue à l'horizon 2030 2030 ça fait
quand même assez long alors on est
encore roger voilà il faut agir avant
parce qu'on ne sait pas à quoi
s'attendre dans cinq ans en terme de
congestion routière
si on doit attendre 2030 dans dix ans
pour pouvoir commencer à réfléchir si on
n'avait pas pris les mesures
nécessaire bien en avant on risque
d'être confronté a quand même pas mal de
problèmes mais ça veut dire qu'il ya des
aménagements à faire en ce sens
certainement certainement car notre
énormément spécialement lorsque vous
partez de chez vous à 8 heures du matin
et que vous arrivez aux commandes hier à
oran prennent des sangliers à guyancourt
c'est une catastrophe sur l'urbanisme
guyancourt est une ville qui a
énormément changé une construction de
logements des réhabilitations vous
souhaité implanter de nouveaux logements
sociaux dans la ville est ce que c'est
nécessaire quand on sait qu'il ya
environ 48 % de logements sociaux déjà %
de logements sociaux tout je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous néanmoins on se
retrouve quand même dans une
problématique à guyancourt où vous avez
des gens qui ont des demandes de
logement qui n'aboutissent pas tout
simplement qu'ils ont une demande de
logements qui datent de 5 7 10 ans et
qui n'a pas donné qu'il n'y a pas de
solution pour aujourd'hui c'est
davantage les aider voilà sachant que
dans cette démarche ces gens là voient
des constructions sortir de terre
d'année en année et ils ne peuvent pas
en être bénéficiaire et quelques autres
axes forts de votre programme quelles
sont la sécurité la sécurité je pense
que la plupart des candidats nous avons
des points communs en termes de
programme c'est juste les solutions que
l'on va proposer qui est différente
voilà tout à fait donc pour nous
l'éducation est prioritaire nous avons
ensuite la sécurité nous avons également
l'écologie et c'est ce que nous allons
proposer prochainement au bouillant
courtois et puis on courtois lors de nos
débats et tout ce programme ces projets
que vous les portez nécessite forcément
un lien fort avec l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines tout à fait ce
que les liens actuels sont satisfaisants
est-ce qu'il faut les renforcer sinon je
pense qu'il est impératif de les
renforcer aujourd'hui il y a cette
déconnexion entre la population et la
ville on la retrouve également avec la
communauté d'agglomération
malgré ce qu'on ne peut nous dire en
conseil de ré ont cassé
nicipal sur le terrain c'est autre chose
un mot sur votre liste pour terminer ce
qu'elle est totalement constitué vous
êtes encore la recherche de coalitions
nous sommes encore à la recherche de
talents on va dire tous tous différents
on va dire nous sommes ouverts à tout le
monde sans distinction de religion de
condition sociale ou autre vous êtes
français vous voulez vous investir pour
l'aiguiller en courtoisie gluant
courtois rejoignez donc une place forte
de nos citoyens on voit fleurir des
démarches citoyennes dans tout l'est
dans toute l'école si les démarches
citoyennes justement quand vous y
regarder de plus près à ce forme
justement parce que jusqu'au niveau 2 au
niveau des politiques anti roland s'y
retrouve plus tout simplement et vos
prochains rendez vous avec les clients
courtois justement dans la troisième
semaine de janvier
non on n'a pas encore défini une date il
faut qu'on fasse une réservation de ses
relais auprès des services municipaux et
vous en serez informés
merci m avait là des coups que je
rappelle que vous êtes là c est la tête
de liste de l'union des démocrates
musulmans français à guyancourt pour ces
municipales dans cette ville quatre
autres listes sont en course celle du
maire et divers gauche sortant françois
marteau en aiguille en cours pour tous
nouvel élan pour guyancourt sera
conduite par grégory pape soutenu par la
république en marche olivier par les ja
sont en lice pour décidons ensemble à
guyancourt une liste participative enfin
rodolphe barry conduire à la candidate à
la candidature ensemble agissons pour
guillon cours